celui du rapatriement des enfants de
djihadistes ces français qui sont partis
faire la guerre au moyen-orient en
particulier en syrie et en irak
les parlementaires un certain nombre
d'entreprises directement emmené par
bérengère politiques et députés
les républicains des ardennes a envoyé
une lettre à emmanuel macron pour lui
demander que devenait ses enfants il
faut qu'une évaluation soit diligentée
dans les plus brefs délais par le
gouvernement sur les conditions
d'accueil précise ce courrier avant
toute nouvelle admission afin d'adapter
notre qualité d'accueil
alors d'après les chiffres dont nous
disposons il y à déjà 169 enfants qui
sont rentrés et 35 d'entre eux venaient
de caen syriens qui sont sous le
contrôle kurde et il resterait encore
300 enfants dans les camps syrien le
retour de ces enfants est complexe parce
que ils reviennent en général avec leur
mère laquelle est incarcéré dès son
arrivée en france et donc ses enfants
sont placés et par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance et contenus des horreurs
qu'ils ont vécu il ya évidemment de
graves difficultés
olivier babeau il ya un article du
figaro sur ce sujet qui a suscité un
grand nombre de commentaires on en était
à 350 tout à l'heure qui sont presque
tous négatifs c'est-à-dire qu'ils
considèrent que ces familles ont fait
des choix et que c'est triste pour ses
enfants mais qu' il ne faut pas
rapatrier ces gens et ce
des comptes est révélateur des sondages
sur le sur le principe à ce que vous
considérez que la france a le devoir de
récupérer ses enfants
et comme on peut parler prendre tout
seul de rapatrier aussi leur mère ou
bien est ce que il faudrait qu'ils
assument leurs responsabilités je crois
qu'il faut être très clair pour la
nationalité française si je ne me trompe
pas c'est une forme de droit du sang
c'est à dire si vous êtes fils de
français vous êtes français à partir du
moment où vous avez la nationalité
française
la france a une un devoir envers vous de
voir d'une forme de protection quand
vous êtes un enfant vous n'êtes pas
responsables de ce qu'ont fait vos
parents aussi mal qu'est pu agir vos
parents vous ne pouvez pas en être
considérée comme responsable c'est ma
position donc je trouve que c'est à
l'honneur de la france d'avoir une aide
sociale à l'enfance qui prennent en
charge ces enfants en prenant en compte
probablement le caractère
particulièrement difficile de leur
situation des traumatismes dont avait
parlé peut-être des gens qui a donc à
terme qui devront faire l'objet je ne
sais pas peut-être quand ils seront plus
grands d'une surveillance particulière
j'en sais rien mais a priori ce sont pas
des citoyens de seconde zone
tant qu'ils ont cette nationalité leurs
parents les longs aussi et bien c'est le
principe qu'on doit soutenir on doit les
accueillir on doit les rapatrier 6
si on en a la possibilité même s'ils
peuvent constituer une forme de menace
c'est ce que considère nos internautes 1
à 72% alors pour l'instant il n'y a pas
eu de deux faits de violences commises
par ses enfants
de retour en france même si on signale
l'un d'entre eux de 12 ans qui aurait
fait le signe d'un égorgement pour
vis-à-vis d'une d'une personne qui était
en charge de s'en occuper
guillaume bigot il ya le rapatriement
des enfants qu'il ya le fait aussi et
qu' il faut les rapatrier seul ou avec
avec leurs parents ces deux sont des
choix difficiles à les parents et
surtout les hommes la france ne veut pas
et elle a bien raison
ils ont pris les armes contre le pays
sont des bombes à retardement les femmes
souvent ont mené la vie très dure aux
populations locales il faut et
d'ailleurs ils ont souvent ces femmes
aussi ont des comptes à rendre parce que
l'événement seulement le zèle des
nouveaux convertis il y avait sept cette
extrême brutalité dont ont témoigné
beaucoup de syrienne et beaucoup
d'irakiennes vous avez qu'elles étaient
souvent chargés de la police de la
police religieuse et elle a été
particulièrement cruelle et redouté de
la population donc souvent ces femmes
ont des comptes à rendre localement aux
syriens et et aux irakiens qu'elles ont
qu'elles ont malmené ensuite ces enfants
effectivement c'est ça percute
complètement notre vision rousseauiste
des choses puisque on est très très
influencé par cette cette idée de
rousseau que l'enfant naît naturellement
bon et c'est la société qui le rend
méchant alors effectivement là ils ont
été dressés souvent pour être ce qu'ils
appelaient les lionceaux du califat
comme tous les les idéologies
totalitaires il misait sur la
fabrication d'un homme nouveau et cet
homme il devait être sans pitié et
abattre le coup phare de sorte que
certains de ces enfants ont joué avec
des têtes humaines ont eux-mêmes égorgé
et c'est donc évidemment c'est très
compliqué je crois que la césure la
coupure c'est quand même l'adolescence
c'est à dire qu'à l'enfant et
l'adolescent
je pas spécialiste du tout mais il me
semble que les oeufs les jeunes enfants
sont probablement amendable
et probablement la france effectivement
ce se grandirait à accueillir ces
enfants à les remettre à leurs
grands-parents tout cas si c'est
possible ou alors des familles d'accueil
et l'aide sociale à l'enfance et quand
même c'est faire ça et se peut se
charger de sa les adolescents les jeunes
adultes etc
ça paraît quand même beaucoup plus
compliqué ensuite il ya un autre
problème qui apparemment est un problème
juridique auquel s'est heurté le l'état
c'est que dans notre droit sol un
magistrat peut décider de séparer un
enfant de sa mère est apparemment dans
les camps sur la surveillance des kurdes
ou d'ailleurs on ira comme en syrie si
la mer est d'accord on peut séparer
l'enfant et l'ont rapatrié
mais l'état français craint qu'une fois
l'enfant ici il y ait des recours qu'ils
soient formés et que l'on soit ça
devienne une situation disons un casse
tête juridique et juridiquement infernal
donc en réalité je pense que les jeunes
enfants oui ils sont probablement
amendable oui il faut probablement les
les rapatrier les femmes ont des comptes
à rendre et à mon avis elles ont aussi
des comptes à rendre et peut-être
surtout des comptes à rendre sur place
aux gens qu elles ont qu'elles ont
persécuté donc si on ramène des enfants
c'est prononçant les maçons les maires
et quant aux enfants trop âgées il faut
demander aux spécialistes mais il ya
probablement se sont trop lents des
bombes à retardement ça c'est sûr je
précise que nous n'avons pas réussi à
trouver en tout cas je n'ai pas réussi à
retrouver des statistiques par la jda
rage enfants donc en fait on ne sait pas
l'âge qu'ils ont été jusqu'à jusqu'à
quel âge est ce qu'ils sont rapatriés
les pardons mais s'ils sont nés dans le
califat on peut imaginer qu'ils ont
entre cinq et dix ans devrait
probablement pour moyenne effectivement
depuis le début du conflit
des enfants qui depuis tout petit ont
été élevés dans une doctrine comme 16 à
leurs parents ne peuvent pas être libéré
de ce dont on les a imprégné nous dit
patrick jullien les rapatriés pourquoi
pas mais à condition qu'il y ait un
suivi psychologique et du katif
rigoureux olivier babeau le principe
l'idée qu'on puisse peut-être de façon
plus systématique que séparer les
enfants de leurs parents
ça vous choque ou après tout est-ce que
ces femmes et ces hommes d'ailleurs ont
fait le choix d'être d'aller là bas on
peut dire que ce sont devenus des
ennemis de la france puisqu'ils ont pris
les armes contre nous mêmes de façon
indirecte et que donc tant pis ou alors
non c'est pas humain
malheureusement ça arrive assez souvent
quand des parents sont condamnés à la
prison ils sont séparés de leurs enfants
quand des parents d'ailleurs sur jugé
nocif pour leurs enfants
j'ai l'impression quand même que là
c'est le cas de nos points de vue ils
sont séparés de leurs enfants
donc non c'est pas choquant c'est
toujours regrettable mais c'est pas
choquant quand vous avez des parents
dont on peut penser qu'ils qu'ils ont
une forme de toxicité alors après le la
surveillance bon bah c'est plus
généralement le contrôle de toutes les
formes de radicalisation là au moins on
alors non on sait qui c'est on va s'en
occuper
c'est par un nombre qui paraît pour
l'instant 169 peut-être plus les 300
s'est pas très bien c'est un nombre
qu'on peut aborder sans doute c'est un
traitement particulier c'est un suivi
particulier je pense que il faut pas
nécessairement
enfin il faut pas les traiter en tout
cas il faut pas que ça soit uniquement
les méthodes n'importe quel enfant de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance et
probablement des choses à inventer mais
on peut cesser toutes là c'est tout
l'honneur de nos civilisations de donner
sa chance à un enfant aussi est ce que
les enfants de nazis ont été ont été
arrêtés est ce qu on a considéré qu'il
était bon acheter qui avait rien à faire
absolument pas et je pense que bon ça
veut pas dire qu'il y aura pas
malheureusement des enfants déjà
radicalisé mais ça veut dire aussi qu'il
y aura des gens qui ont une vie tout à
fait normale et ce sera notre honneur de
l'avoir permis l'autre sujet c'est celui
des parents là aussi il ya débat au sein
de la classe politique pour savoir si
ils doivent être jugés en france parce
que c'est à la justice française qui
doivent rendre des comptes
ou bien est-ce qu'ils doivent rester sur
place et ses taux au pouvoir en place en
irak en syrie ou éventuellement dans les
régions dominées par les kurdes les
kurdes qui quittent qui doivent les
juges et les sanctionner
qu'en pensez vous guillaume bigot
écouter ils ont ils
il faut d'abord de vous intéresser
d'abord les premiers intéressés sont les
irakiens et des syriens
et c'est là où ils ont commis leur
forfait et leurs méfaits donc je pense
que c'est là où ils doivent rendre des
comptes et où la justice doit être
rendue par les syriens et par les
irakiens
ensuite derrière alors l'exemple des
déités ryong -on est très bons parce
qu'il y avait des études de sociologues
américains dans l'est dans les années 70
66 en disait beaucoup de cadres de la
démocratie chrétienne ou au delà des
socialistes en allemagne c'est des gens
qui ont fait la république fédérale
d'allemagne démocratique qui était d
iter young guns et i les hitler jugend
on a complètement refoulé ça mais en
réalité c'était des gens qui étaient
dressés à la n dri c'est la cruauté la
doctrine hitlérienne d'ailleurs elle se
rapproche ont cela de la doctrine
djihadistes c'était vraiment d'arracher
toute espèce de pitié et c'est ça qui
est fort enfin pour ces fous
sanguinaires qui formidable chez les
enfants c'est qu'ils sont c'est une
c'est une pêche blanche sont extrêmement
malléable
donc en ce sens c'est l'idée de rousseau
évidemment fausse et bayer le bien n'est
pas installée dans le coeur de l'enfant
l'enfant il devient d'une certaine façon
ce que l'adulte il résulte ces dindes un
façonnage culturelle par l'adulte bon
parenthèse fermée donc pas répondre à
votre question je pense que aussi ce qui
fait peur et la sur-réaction pour le
monde de l'opinion publique est dû au
fait que d'une certaine façon cette
idéologie tout le monde le sait enfin
peu de pas trop y penser elle nous
infecte en fait elle et elle est déjà là
il ya des gens qui sont convaincus par
ses parts c'est par ses idéaux et on a
du mal à évaluer la dangerosité
bon il faut pas il faut ni en faire une
vision alarmiste en lisant que ça y'est
toutes les banlieues sont devenu
djihadiste est complètement faux mais ni
non plus faire les autruches en réalité
milhas a et donc on se dit ben il y en a
un qui rapatrié c'est déjà un de trop et
ça va continuer à faire des émules c'est
ça que nous craignons et en fait on sort
on se rend compte qu'en fait ils sont
venus de chez nous d'abord et c'est chez
nous qu'ils ont souvent été radicalisé
et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont fait cette
ce chemin et cette démarche d'aller
prendre des armes et de faire le djihad
donc de toute façon il faut bien
expliquer la population que le mal aidé
chez nous et qu'il faut l'affronter et
enfin pour terminer ce qui est très
différent de la situation de troisième
reich en 45 c'est que l'idéologie nazie
a été écrasée avec le reich et donc il
ya eu un écrasement militaire donc là il
ya eu un écrasement militaire de dèche
n'y a pas eu du tout d'écrasement
militaire de d'écrasement de l'idéologie
au contraire dans la doctrine
djihadistes au contre la doctrine des
surhommes
nazis c'était qu'ils étaient les plus
forts alors là ils n'étaient pas les
plus forts ils ont été ensevelis sous
les bombes incendiaires anglo-américaine
donc là maintenant après les allemands
sont pas devenus gentiment démocrates
ils ont été écrasés et ensuite
évidemment dont leur doctrine à eux ils
ne pouvaient plus prétendre être les
plus forts dans le djihadisme ce qui est
gênant c'est qu'il ya un culte du martyr
est donc là évidemment au contraire plus
on en tue et plus ça suscite des émules
c'est ça qui aiderait très gênant aux
libéraux c'est sans doute pour ça que
les responsables politiques de notre
pays sont très très discret sur ce sujet
bien que la chaîne eric dupond moretti
avait dit qu'il était favorable au
rapatriement des djihadistes même pour
être jugé en france depuis qu'il est
garde des sceaux et ne s'exprime plus là
dessus
et si les français sont très
majoritairement contre ce rapatriement
c'est sans doute parce que ils se disent
ils vont continuer en france d'une
manière ou d'une autre à prospérer cette
idéologie fois que ce sujet
effectivement est un sujet qui provoque
beaucoup de malaise parce qu'en réalité
il nous tend il nous montre le miroir de
nos propres problèmes parce qu'on ait
fait cette ne serait jamais parti si le
problème n'était pas chez nous donc le
problème il est moins c'est quelques
centaines d'enfants éventuellement qui
vont qui vont revenir que le fait que
l'on sait très bien que ça existe déjà
chez nous ça veut dire que c'est partout
mais c'est qu'on sait que c'est là et
malheureusement on a régulièrement
quelques fous dont on ne sait pas très
bien quelle est la part de la de la
pathologie psychiatrique et puis on sait
que malheureusement l'endoctrinement est
aussi un endroit sur lesquels les
pathologies psychiatriques ont beaucoup
de prises c'est à dire que ça déclenche
ça aide c'est un phénomène qui va aider
à la cristallisation mais qui fait que
bon bah il ya beaucoup de dengue
évidemment qui font peu près ce que
heureusement du terrorisme los teques
low cost c'est à dire un terroriste qui
va malheureusement c'est toujours âpre
va tuer des gens mais c'est pas un
terroriste alors on septembre préparé
avec plusieurs milliers de morts et
quelque chose ça va pas très loin mais
c'est terrible parce qu'on a
l'impression que justement c'est
insaisissable on n'arrive pas à le
prévoir que le passage à l'acte ne peut
pas se réveille je pense que c'est la
vraie angoisse en fait qu'on a tous
aujourd'hui c'est cette espèce de deux
terroristes qui provoque vraiment au
sens propre la terreur la peur du fait
que n'importe qui sur un trottoir sur
n'importe quelle ville de france et de
navarre peut à tout moment retrouver
quelqu'un comme ça je crois que c'est
surtout ça aujourd'hui
angoisse qui nous étreint et c'est pour
ça que ce problème là nous met en face
de cette angoisse si on n'a pas trop
envie de voir et vous pensez que cette
cette inquiétude
guillaume bigot elle va elle va faire
partie des thèmes de la campagne
présidentielle
ou bien on a le sentiment quand même ou
à contrario plutôt que les les français
ne s'en préoccupe que quand il ya un
attentat et puis qu'ensuite peut-être il
le met le sujet de côté faute peut-être
de solutions pour le régler oui c'est
très juste votre remarque est très très
frappé au coin du bon sens il ya quand
même une
c'est ces présents en tâche de fond
c'est pensez-y toujours n'en parler
jamais c'est vraiment ça et c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment l'irruption de
l'attentât qui rappelle ce qu'on n'a pas
envie de ce qu'on n'a pas envie de voir
pour répondre à la question de la de la
présidentielle le fait qu'il y ait ou
non des attentats et on sait qu'on
rentre dans une zone de danger puisque
on va arriver à l'ouverture du procès
des attentats du 13 novembre et que dans
la doctrine dans la doctrine djihadistes
il y a dix ont la volonté toujours
d'utiliser les symboles
que ce soient des lieux d'ailleurs ils
vont frapper de manière obsessionnelle
au même endroit ou alors pour marquer
des anniversaires etc
bon donc on sait que c'est une zone de
danger et la proche de la présidentielle
aussi donc là bon c'est quelque chose de
dangereux
les il faut vraiment là vraiment c'est
la phrase de kennedy c'est à dire dans
cette affaire de terrorisme je suis bien
d'accord avec olivier babeau il ya
vraiment que la peur qui doit nous faire
peur c'est ça qui est qui est à redouter
c'est que les gens perdent leur enfin le
pays perde son sang-froid ce cas pas été
le cas jusqu'à présent
mais en fait et donc donc il ne faut il
faut bien expliquer que c'est pas
quelques centaines d'enfants en plus qui
peuvent menacer le pays mais qu' il
pourra y avoir dix attentats sans
attente amis l'attentât il ne vaincront
pas de toute façon quoi qu'il arrive
quoi qu'il arrive et il serait
probablement mieux de préparer les
populations comme on sait très bien le
faire en israël en disant écoutez c'est
inévitable plutôt que de dire à chaque
fois qu'un attentat mais que fait la
police est ce qu'on ne pouvais pas
l'éviter c'est vivre dans un rêve
c'est une guerre de trente ans et cette
guerre elle va pas s'arrêter et ceux qui
racontent qu'elle va s'arrêter sont des
menteurs dont il faut préparer la
population à rester ferme
ils ne feront pas bougé un cil des
français qui doivent camper sur leurs
positions et nous les détruirons et nous
vaincrons
mais à la condition de garder confiance
en nous merci beaucoup c'est une belle
conclusion
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivi je
vous souhaite un excellent au week-end à
bientôt